energiekrise und inflation das sind die
themen die uns beschäftigen und nicht
nur uns sondern natürlich auch die
politik und deswegen sprechen wir jetzt
mit dem vorsitzenden der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion mit christian
dürr schönen guten tag herr dürr ich
grüße sie hallo guten morgen welches
auto fahren sie denn privat und in
welchem auto werden sie als
bundesvorsitzender der fdp chauffiert
also privat ich jetzt keine werbung für
einzelne hersteller machen es ist ein
mit der eins anfangen die zahl mit einem
hersteller aus münchen aber elektro oder
fahren sie mit benzin oder diesel das
ist tatsächlich ein benziner und wenn
sid wenn sie fragen wollen was ist dem
was der fraktionsvorsitzende verband das
ist ein hybridauto
im 1 ja unsere gleiches gleich
hersteller von unserer ich will keine
werbung machen wir haben ganz viele
tolle hersteller deutschland inhaltlich
ein falscher eindruck entsteht unsere
bildseite 2 zeigt heute soll dieser
kuhhandel die ampel retten die fdp will
kein generelles tempolimit spd und grüne
wollen keine laufzeitverlängerung der
letzten drei deutschen atomkraftwerke
würden sie das tempolimit jetzt gegen
akw laufzeiten tauschen
also ich glaube dass die überschrift
kuhhandel trifft es schon ganz gut es
bringt ja nichts etwas zu tun was uns im
herbst und winter überhaupt gar nicht
helfen würde wir haben ja einen direkten
zusammenhang zwischen strommarkt
einerseits und dem gasverbrauch
andererseits denn soweit gehört wir
nutzen in deutschland immer noch erdgas
zur verstromung insbesondere für diesen
sogenannten grundlastfähigen strom das
heißt man schaltet die waschmaschine an
muss es auch wirklich strom im netz dazu
brauchen wir grundlast und das
gewährleisten eben auch kernkraftwerke
deswegen unser vorschlag über den 31
dezember hinaus die drei sicheren
deutschen kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen zu
lassen um eines zu erreichen dass kein
einziger kubikmeter gas der dringend zu
die haushalte gelingt für die industrie
benötigt wird dass der mäher verstromt
werden muss und da hilft natürlich ein
tempolimit an der stelle gar nicht denn
das was sie an der tankstelle tanken ist
ja nicht teil des strommarktes aber wie
sieht es aus würden sie das wirklich
dann eintauschen wenn die ganz zustimmen
ja ich wiederhole mich noch mal was
bringt dann etwas was vermeintlich
politisch interessant klingt aber uns
über den winter überhaupt gar nicht
helfen würde es gibt ja verschiedene
studien die sagen also das was ein
tempolimit in der sache bringt allein
bei den markt zu benzin und diesel ist
faktisch gegen null also das mal
beiseite geschoben selbst wenn es etwas
bringen würde ist unsere ganz konkrete
mögliche energielücke die wir alle
gemeinsam oder sind sicher auch alle
andere partner einig verhindern wollte
zu den herbst und winter für diese
energielücke ist das eben keinen beitrag
und was bringt es denn etwas zu machen
wenn es in der sache nicht hilft sondern
nur politisch vermeintlich schick
aussieht in der sache müssen wir einmal
feststellen es geht nicht darum alte
atomdebatten wieder aufzumachen es geht
nicht darum auch alten wunden
aufzureißen und es geht darum ganz
konkret einen versorgungsengpass im
winter zu verhindern deswegen wäre mein
wunsch dass wir dazu ernsthaftigkeit zu
bekommen und diese spielerische außen
vor lassen wie sieht es denn mit dem
tank rabatt aus inwiefern wird es damit
weitergehen bei den tank rabatt ist ja
auf drei monate befristet er hat
funktioniert da gab es ja unten ruf am
anfang dass das nicht geholfen hat und
es war wichtig dass zumindest jetzt
machst du drei monate wir dort
insbesondere die pendlerinnen und
pendler also diejenigen die aufs auto
angewiesen sind die gar keine
alternativen haben weil sie im
ländlichen raum wurden beispielsweise
dass die entlastung erfahren haben und
was jetzt greift insbesondere in den
kommenden wochen bereits sind ja die
beschlossenen steuerlichen entlastung
der ampel da ja die einkommensteuer
grundfreibetrag viele andere dinge
rückwirkend zum ersten januar reduziert
das kommt jetzt langsam auf den konten
der menschen an also wir haben an
verschiedenen stellen etwas getan beim
tanken aber eben auch direkt bei der
einkommensteuer kommt dann eben auch
direkt bei den menschen an das war uns
wichtig dass es nicht versandet ob es
direkt bei den menschen ankommt ist ja
die frage mit dem blick auf die
steigenden energiekosten die abschlag
abschlagszahlung für gas sollen sich
verdreifachen und viele menschen fragen
sich wirklich wie sie das dann bezahlen
sollen wie kann der staat konkret helfen
ich sagte foren die steuerlichen
entlastung wenn man sich anschaut was
wir bei einem so genannten
heizkostenzuschuss gemacht haben das
betrifft die menschen die wenig
einkommen haben auf wohngeld angewiesen
sind aber ein heizkostenzuschuss jetzt
in der auszahlung wenn es mal für eine
vierköpfige familie sich anschauen dann
sind das knapp 1150 euro an entlastung
das ist zumindest schon mal was der
staat wird es sicherlich nicht schaffen
die komplette inflation aus zugreifen
auszugleichen aber wir werden uns jetzt
im herbst um einen zweiten schritt
kümmern der aus meiner sicht eine riesen
ungerechtigkeit darstellt und das ist
diese sogenannte kalte progression das
heißt dass menschen haben real gar nicht
mehr in der tasche aber zahlen wegen des
steuertarifs in deutschland höhere
steuern und das müssen wir als nächstes
ausgleichen also gerade kleine und
mittlere einkommen die real nicht mehr
in der tasche haben gestiegene preise im
supermarkt sehen dass die dann nicht
mehr steuern zahlen das ist das nächste
worum wir uns kümmern wollen aber das
passiert schlussendlich alles auf dem
rücken der mittelständler oder also ich
meine die schere zwischen arm und reich
sie wird doch immer größer
nein da geht es ja insbesondere um
diejenigen in der mitte der gesellschaft
um die mittleren einkommen die bei der
kalten progression entlastet werden
sollen also insofern ganz im gegenteil
diese schere droht auseinander zu gehen
wenn man nichts tut aber deswegen ja
unser vorschlag den steuer teilnehmer
etwas zu machen um gerade diejenigen die
mittlere einkommen haben entsprechend
auch zu entlasten weil es ist unfair
wenn jemand sehr hart arbeitet 40
stunden die woche und jetzt auf einmal
feststellt dass er sogar mehr steuern
zahlen muss das darf natürlich nicht
sein und deswegen wollen wir uns um den
punkt gemacht
ich würde gerne mit ihnen noch ein thema
ansprechen was den herbst und corona
betrifft da hat der bundesjustizminister
buschmann gesagt dass er sich vorstellen
kann dass dann wieder regelungen zum
tragen einer maske im innenraum
vorschrift sind bedeutet das für alle
bürger dass wir in öffentlichen gebäuden
aber nicht nur da öffentlicher
nahverkehr natürlich sowieso aber auch
die kinder in schulen in kitas wieder
maske tragen müssen also das was marco
buschmann gesagt hat ist dass er sich
vorstellen kann was die maske eine rolle
spielt übrigens gar nicht so sehr aus
schließlich den corona wir am ja die
sorge sagen auch die mediziner dass der
heftige instruments sie sagen also
grippesaison bekommen das ist unter
umständen noch
unter diesen winter als die korona
situation die zum glück ja im griff ist
trotz hoher infektionszahlen haben wir
eben keine auslastung über auslastung
des gesundheitssystems aber lassen sie
mich zum thema schulen etwas sagen beim
auch wenn winter sicherlich wie heute
schon möglichen v die maske rolle
spielen ich halte sehr viel davon die
schulen besonders zu schützen ich halte
sehr viel davon sehr klar zu sagen dass
es keine schulschließung mehr geben wird
und ich will an der stelle ganz konkret
zum klassenzimmer was sagen ich erwarte
von den ministerpräsidenten
insbesondere von den beiden recht lauten
ministerpräsidenten winfried kretschmann
und markus söder aus dem süden dass sie
gewährleisten dass die klassenzimmer im
winter sicher sind auch ohne maske
tragen denn wir haben jetzt zwei drei
winterzeit lüftungsgeräte einzubauen
jetzt ist der sommer sozusagen last call
jetzt muss es wirklich gelten ich will
keine bilder im winter sehen wo junge
menschen mit mütze und schal sitzen weil
die fenster aufgerissen werden müssen
das darf nicht wieder passieren und da
sind den ministerpräsidenten
da sind die länder in der pflicht dafür
zu sorgen dass alle klassenzimmer in
deutschland so ausgestattet sind dass
der unterricht in präsenz und sicher
stattfinden kann und wir möchten
natürlich keine bilder sehen von armen
und alten menschen die sich in wärme
hallen aufwärmen müssen weil sie sich
die energiekosten in ihren eigenen
wohnungen nicht mehr leisten können was
können sie dem entgegen setzen dass das
eben nicht passiert in einem so reichen
land wie deutschland
ein erster schritt haben wir gemacht ich
hatte es vor in einem nebensatz erwähnt
dieser sogenannte heizkostenzuschuss den
wir auszahlen das betrifft ja gerade die
wohngeldempfänger und das sind genau die
menschen die sie meinen mit kleinen und
mittleren einkommen
da haben wir sind wir dabei sehr konkret
diesen menschen zu helfen aber ich will
ihnen sagen was der staat als
allererstes tun muss er muss selbst
dafür sorge tragen dass das
energieangebot nicht knapp wird und das
heißt eben auch dass uns keiner weiteren
optionen berauben dürften deswegen auch
unser hinweis auf die verlängerung der
laufzeiten da geht es nicht nur darum
eine lücke im winter eine energielücke
zu verhindern sondern es geht auch darum
den den preis zu stabilisieren im markt
wenn das angebot größer ist wenn es
nicht künstlich durch staatliches
handeln reduziert wird dann
stabilisieren sich auch die preise und
natürlich ist die sorge am markt groß
dass weitere energien abgeschaltet
werden bei der kohle haben wir jetzt
leider muss ich sagen mussten jetzt
gezwungenermaßen eine rolle rückwärts
machen und kohlekraftwerke mit 1 netz
bringen was schlechtes klima ist aber
dringend notwendig aus den genannten
gründen und ich empfehle gleiches bei
der kernenergie damit sich die preise
endlich wieder stabilisieren auch das
ist ein beitrag gerade er anderen
menschen zu helfen was glauben sie wo
stehen wir in ein bis zwei jahren
ja in ein bis zwei jahren hoffe ich dass
wir eine andere energiepolitik
eingeführt haben ersten schritt hat die
ampel jahr getan wir haben
beispielsweise endlich die planungs und
genehmigungszeiten bei den erneuerbaren
energien deutlich verkürzt und sind da
jetzt schneller unterwegs das war ja von
der union lange versprochen da ist nie
was passiert wir werden weitermachen an
der stelle der planungs und
genehmigungszeiten und in dem
zusammenhang empfehle ich auch dort
dringt dass wir uns keine option
berauben der grund warum die fdp für
einen beibehalt des verbrennungsmotors
ist ist ja nicht weil wir gegen
klimaschutz werden sondern ganz im
gegenteil weil der verbrenner mit co2
neutralen kraftstoffen die es in zukunft
geben wird ein beitrag zum klimaschutz
leisten könnte wir werden nur so die
klimaschutzziele erreichen also meine
prognose lautet wir werden
richtigerweise eine politik machen
anders als in der vergangenheit die
nicht immer mehr abschaltet zu immer
mehr nein sagt sondern mehr jahr sagt
und das ganze möglichst co2 neutral co2
neutralität pariser klimaschutz hier das
bleibt unser ziel als koalition aber
gleichzeitig wollen wir eben nicht immer
mehr abschalten denn das kostet nur ganz
ganz viel geld trifft die armen der
ärmsten in aller regel und führt dazu
dass wir solche engpässe kommen den wir
uns jetzt leider gegenübersehen diese
politik muss geändert werden
christian dörr vorsitzender der
fdp-bundestagsfraktion vielen vielen
dank dass sie sich hier heute die zeit
genommen haben ich danke ihnen